The joe rogan experience.
They don't really get their news.
They read the headline and then they act
like they're getting their fucking news.
They're not putting in the
time that aren't reading
the books and actually going
and reading a real newspaper
reading, you know, um,
you know that gentlemen Piss it.
What pisses me off about politics?
I feel like it's the only thing where like
if you don't like, so if you don't, uh,
if Lewis doesn't watch basketball at
all and Jay watches every single sixers
game,
but then there's like a thing coming up
where like something about a basketball
game, Louis won't just like
start arguing with you.
Like not on how they need
to play this defense.
They need to go into a zone
cause you're like, yeah, I just,
I don't really know about that.
But for some reason with politics,
no matter how much anybody's not read
anything, they don't know anything.
They have no problem. Just having
a hardcore strong opinion. Like,
because also you know about it,
right?
So when someone's like super
argumentative about it, like, oh, you're,
you're not even well-informed,
which is most of the case with people
that are really super aggressive about it.
It seems like, I mean, do what they were,
they had this thing where they
were interviewing people at uh,
the fucking march for life.
I think they called it the anti
like gun control march. Well, no,
they were like all over, it's in a bunch
of different cities and how we saw it,
but it happened in a
bunch of different cities.
I think the big ones were in like DC
and I think there was one out here,
but there was this guy just interviewing
people and he'd go around and ask them
if they, uh, if they are foreign assault
weapons band and they'd be like, yes.
And then he'd go,
what's an assault weapon?
And it's amazing how many people
just didn't know. I'm not even,
whatever your take on an assault
weapon ban is, it's like,
how could you be for banning something
that you can't even define as just seems
benign have. Hold on a second.
Yeah, exactly. You're like,
they know that this is what it does.
They know,
they know it's a rifle that shoots people.
It's like a semiautomatic,
it's not a hunting gun.
So rifle is designed to shoot
people like in a military situation.
That's what it looks like.
So they're raw.
I mean like they don't know what an ar 15
versus an or whatever versus like what,
what's legal, what's semiautomatic,
what's, they don't know all the details,
but they do know that these are guns
that you kill people with. Okay, sure.
Fair enough. But I feel like there's like
a thing where there'll be like, well,
while I'm for a ban on semiautomatic
weapons, and they like,
so you want to ban handguns soon? They're
like, no, we don't want to ban handguns.
But that's the kind of guns
or semiautomatic weapons.
It's just like if you're going to protest,
read a book on it.
It's not just having a passive opinion.
You're like out marching, want to,
you know, they want to move
the ball down the field though.
And the more people that come out,
they have kids that are like, you know,
kids are in the fifth grade
walking out of their classrooms.
They don't fucking know what they're
talking about or what they're doing there
as a man. Sometimes there was a girl
with armpit hair. You want to fuck.
You know what I mean?
How many these political opinions
you don't mean that's true or dirty.
Harry feed those girls to the
Harry tone. Um, but I mean,
but how many of these kids,
this is a big one.
How many kids are against putting
kids on psychotropic drugs,
putting kids on unnecessary
psychiatric medications.
Parents dope their kids up all the time,
cause they don't want to deal
with some hyperactive kid.
Some kid has got some fucking power,
some energy bounce off the walls.
And I was in,
we were embraced the other
day, right before the show
we did. And there was a kid,
I mean the kid must have had autism or
or something or some extreme case of it.
Uh, but he was like, you know, he was
having some sort of violent episode,
I'm assuming,
but it was just a dad like commas day,
just sitting on a corner with his kid,
with a kid face down as the kids like
screaming and shaking and kicking his arms
and legs. And then I was just holding
the kid down and it was so hard to like,
I almost wanted to say something like,
I didn't know.
I know they don't ever really
like tell you what to do,
like what's going on in that situation.
And I kind of watch it for a minute cause
it looked like he was abusing the kid
for a second. But then you
kind of realize after like, oh,
this kid's gonna like hurt himself or
whatever it was. But that's like a,
that's like a really, really
hard thing. Yeah, I can,
I can accept more in the real extreme
cases where kids are like severe, severe,
severe problems,
but it seems like they're just happy
to like anyone's like hyperactive,
just this kind of loose things that are
Adderall. It's not a one or a zero. Right.
It's like there's,
there's varying stages of issues that
kids are going to have and some kids are
gonna need some kind of medication,
but they're definitely over prescribing.
Definitely. I knew my, my neighbor had a
kid. There was nothing wrong with them.
It's just a fucking kid. And
they, they put him on Ritalin.
Adderall is a drug man. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's, it's not, yeah. I give it up.
My five year old, we snorted together. If,
if people don't get enough attention or
they don't have an outlet and they don't
know what to do with themselves,
they get wacky.
It doesn't mean you need to
give him drugs. Yeah. Some,
some of these people have
legitimate issues and they
probably do need medication
and some of these people just need to
find something that's interesting in life.
Yeah. Well, I think what you
were saying before about like,
why don't these kids look into that stuff?
I think a lot of times it's just like,
people want the simple thing and
you don't, you've got to actually,
this is a really difficult
question to get into this stuff.
Whereas if you're just like, oh,
I'm against guns, that's easy.
I think it's the same thing as
when people are just offended.
It's like you don't really have to like
read a lot. You don't have to know a lot.
You just easy to be right, and
you've got the answer. It's laziness.
People can just pick a side
very easily and go, cool.
Everyone's already defined what's on that
side. So yeah, I'm on that side. Look,
I did my work right.
Yeah.
Okay.